next a book party hosted by George Mason
University in Virginia and the American
Political Science Association public
policy professor Michael Fauntroy
explores the history of
african-americans and the GOP in his
book Republicans and the black vote this
is 30 minutes
[Music]
the country's becoming black and brown
and at some point you're gonna have to
immigration is depressing like Republic
Latino Republican vote so there is an
opportunity but if you don't reach out
forward most voters are not going to
come to you you have to give them a
reason to join
ken mehlman involved in this at some
level I know when I read somebody's a
consultant trying to talk Republicans
and you may want to give him a buzz
because he made big bag challenge on our
but again but that goes to my bigger
question if you and I had talked why is
it that there are no black that they
would all team to put together this rain
for my way part of that was because
Miley has a show on PBS and he pitched
the ideal okay to PBS yeah and they
decided to go with another question is
where the black Republicans are
sponsoring I really think I think forget
it so I mean just like just like I think
Democrats need to go and stand up in
front of them all right I think we got
to stop doing this thing where we only
willing to talk to folks who agree with
ya again and these candidates get
invitations from all over the place but
they didn't show up at the National
Harbor Lane in strop and n-double-a-cp
and with the Urban League in particular
yeah I'm not talking about a group of
lefty right and and and and I just think
that ultimately the more times you say
no the people that the message gets sent
and we're not interested in you
they were both way today she is now nine
pounds six ounces
and he is ten pounds and 11 ounces no 10
pounds 15 ounces my maiden name her name
is Logan his name is Brett and they are
the doctors just ecstatic about their
grow out wife birthday baby good baby
it's a new birthday baby
I am but I'm working on a new one all
civil rights enforcement federal civil
rights enforcement and some kind of very
early stages of that just got a research
assistant
last time in 1964 when they passed the
Civil Rights Act productivity
was able to get Michael Phan Troy is an
assistant professor at George Mason he
is a very popular professor there with
us and he's popular not only with
students but with his colleagues we are
just so delighted to help delighted to
have him a part of the School of Public
Policy
this is his second book in his young
career and he's already working on his
third one Republicans in the black vote
is as you can see published by the
distinguished publisher Lynn Reiner you
know you he's gotten some jokes a few
jokes like all those three people you're
talking about and I think he'll probably
say a word or two about that this
evening with that I want to say what a
delight it is to introduce my colleague
and friend Michael Fong thank you thank
you very much
Thank You Kathy Kathy was absolutely
right when she said a friend I can set a
Kathy to be a friend she is the reason
why I'm at George Mason and so any of my
failures are her responsibility and I
take total total responsibility for that
thank you all very much for coming this
evening I know you could be somewhere
else and I'm very thankful that you
chose to be here this evening this is a
labor of love and it's very it's a very
thankful opportunity for me to be here
to talk about it it's a it's a topic
that I have been long interested in and
to have the time to actually be able to
write on it research it and talk to so
many other people has been been a real
joy to me intellectually but I spent
most of 2005 and 2006 traveling around
the country conducting interviews
running up my telephone bill talking
with activists former elected officials
current elected officials had the
occasion to speak with former
well then lieutenant governor of
Maryland Michael Steele had a chance to
speak with former representative JC
Watts and a whole host of other
african-american Republican activists
academics and others to try to get a
handle on this in addition to reading
thousands of pages of documents and just
trying to put it all together in a way
that made sense to me and enable me to
talk a little bit about it to others it
gave me a real sense of how
rough-and-tumble American politics can
really be it's a bottom-line business
too often we get caught up into sort of
the idealistic and idealized sense of
what we think politics should be but
it's really not like that in the
relationship between African Americans
and the Republican Party to me sort of
exemplifies how relationships can can
build can start can flourish and
ultimately collapse and so learning that
is sort of been a it yet another lesson
in our politics really operate now Cathy
talked about the jokes and for that
reason I think it's important to lay out
what the book is and is not and I spoke
once at a cocktail party with a friend
of mine and you know you you have
conversations with you people that you
don't see very infrequently what are you
up to what are you doing these days and
I mentioned I was working on a book on
African Americans and and the Republican
Party and he just sort of paused and
sipped his merlot and he said well you
know I sounds like a pamphlet not
necessarily
and that comment and the thinking behind
that comment to me explains why the book
is so necessary because while there
doesn't appear to be a lot going on
right now there's a hundred and fifty
year history that I think needs to be
laid out and and discussed openly now
some of my Republican friends sort of
treated like a Roman romance novel you
know how do we come out in the end you
know my Democratic friends want to know
well we're good I'm glad you're writing
this book cuz we need to expose these
folks and and so and and and I edited
these folks by the way there's some
harsh Allegra's that they've used and
and again the polls on this sort of
pushed me toward a more nuanced look at
this topic you know the fact is that
this book isn't an apology for the
Republican Party in its history
with african-americans nor is it a
screed against the Republican Party in
its history with african-americans so in
that regard it's somewhat disappointing
to both sides so as you know we're in
this pre primary election season and for
me this is a really good time to be
talking about the book and as you know
next week Republicans are gathering in
Baltimore for a nationally televised
forum at Morgan State University and
historically black institution I guess I
should say some of the Republican
presidential candidates are going to
gather in Baltimore because it has been
reported that the top four candidates
have already declined invitations to to
appear in perhaps others may pull out as
well I understand that candidates get
bombarded for it for event requests all
the time and it would be foolhardy to
try to attempt to it appear at every
possible candidate forum but I think if
the Republicans really want to reach out
to minority voters it may be
to show up at events that are organized
and are situated in menus that are
focused on minorities so I think it's a
mistake I think it's an opportunity
missed and it's my hope that going
forward that Republican candidates will
be more aggressive in their outreach
toward all minorities not just African
Americans as you know most of the
top-tier Republican candidates did not
attend the National Urban League
convention in st. Louis this summer they
also missed the n-double-a-cp can
convention this summer they did not
appear at a candidate forum that was
sponsored by Univision and aired
nationally on Univision and by the way
the Democratic candidate forum that was
hosted by Univision drew more viewers
than anything that has been done on
MSNBC or CNN and the point there is that
there are viewers and listeners and
voters out there who are not being
reached through the so-called normal
channels and then again this is an
opportunity missed so let me shift now
and talk a little bit about the book and
I'm going to go to the end and just sort
of talk about some of the conclusions I
really think that the historical
relationship between African Americans
in the Republican Party while
significant factual long-standing and
important is somewhat overstated by
those who seek to explain why African
Americans should come home to the
Republican Party which is what I've
heard on numerous occasions a Republican
Party activist often talked about the
party of Lincoln and this historical
connection between African Americans in
the Republican Party and that historical
connection is absolutely correct
the Republican Party was founded on
liberal social principles the notion
that slavery should be abolished a
notion that there should be civil rights
there should be integration there should
be an attempt to bring people together
as opposed to separating people
and and and it is absolutely correct and
proper to mention that history but I
think over time when you look at the
Hayes tilt and compromising in 1877 and
since what you find is a circumstance in
which the Republican Party and
african-americans began to move in
different directions some of that was a
push and pull Republicans in the south
in particular we're having a difficult
time competing for for voters because
Democrats in that era during that era
were saying that the Republican Party
was a party for blacks and if you want
to support you know black interest in
you vote Republican and in those days
that was certainly not the sort of
message that was a winner at the ballot
box for Republicans so at that time you
began to see Republicans back away from
some of the historical commitments to
African Americans at the same time as
you move into the twentieth century
particularly in the 1930s as you get
toward the in the response to the Great
Depression you begin to see as a result
of the great migration of
african-americans from the south to
northern cities where they were
beginning to make a difference and who
got elected because of the sheer numbers
Democrats began to reach out to African
Americans so you had a push on one hand
and a pull on the other and I think that
push and pull has helped to set up what
we have right now which is a
circumstance in which ninety percent of
African Americans vote for Democrats now
that is an enormous number but it was
you know if they were polling them when
you look at all the historical data is
quite clear that even more African
Americans supported the Republican Party
during the abolition movement and during
reconstruction so how did we get from a
circumstance in which the Republicans
had near unanimous support from African
Americans to now near unanimous
opposition so that's that's some of the
focus that I try to build from and so
this push and pull has set off a
multi-generational movement in which
African
Americans have been at some points
marginalized and demonized in Republican
politics there is a movement that took
place in the post Reconstruction era
through the early 20th century called
the lily-white movement in which the
Republican Party literally began to
purge African Americans from positions
of authority in many southern states but
most notably in Texas and Louisiana and
again this is not the sort of message
you want to send to people that you
believe ought to be a part of what you
are all about and so what we have now is
a situation as you fast-forward to our
contemporary period the last generation
or so you know it's very interesting
Richard Nixon has gone down in history
as you know the perpetrator of some some
great fraud against the Constitution
with regard to Watergate but in
comparison to his Republican
predecessors most notably President
Ronald Reagan and current President
George Bush on racial issues Nixon was
quite the moderate notwithstanding the
sort of symbolic politics that took
place and his embrace of the Southern
Strategy that led to his election in
1968 and so as you look at the the
growing bubbling significant those small
cadre of african-american Republicans
that were beginning to make headway in
the Republican Party during the Nixon
years much of that began to get stamped
out during the Reagan years and that is
lamentable in part because there are so
many african-american Republicans who
want to rebuild those bridges between
the party and african-americans but it
can temporarily at least it just doesn't
appear to be enough of an institutional
will with the party at the national
level to make that happen
now I've had conversations with state
party activists and city activists not
just here in this area but around the
country and at that level there is an
understanding of the political
demographics that are taken
place in the country would say the
Republican Party may well go the way of
the Whigs if they continue to falter
with african-american and Latino voters
given the demographic changes that are
taking place in the country but yet but
but at to this point at least the
National Party has not fully embraced
the notion that they need to go out and
commit and compete for African American
and other minority voters and so we have
a circumstance right now in which going
into the 2008 elections the Republican
Party is in in really difficult straits
when you look at the electoral map you
see that the Republicans are doing very
poorly with Latino voters they did
horribly with African American voters
and you know I lay this statistic on
people and and some of them sort of are
blown away by it but in 2004 President
Bush did twice as good twice as well
with gay voters than he did with
african-american voters and in 2004 and
think about that given the circumstances
in which the president found himself
with with with african-american voters
so when you think about that it tells
you how high the mountain is that the
Republican Party has to climb in order
to win more african-american support
when more Latino support but the party
in my opinion is going to have to try to
do this because demographically if it
doesn't it's going to become a regional
party and I think that is a mistake for
or rather a problem for everyone now my
Republican friends tell me wait a second
Civil Rights Act was spearheaded by
Republicans much of the civil rights
legislation of the 1960's had at least
not if not majority at least significant
Republican support why don't people
remember that I think people do remember
that but what people also remember is
Willie Horton and some of the other
political symbolism that has taken place
over the course of legend
which has given the message to
african-american voters that for our
purposes we can win without you and so
we will continue to do what we need to
do to try to win without you but again
demographically that becomes a problem
so the Republican Party has has this now
multi-generational history of purging
demonizing and otherwise marginalizing
african-american voters in this couple
with a suit similar history of negative
racial symbolism and public policy that
had been seen as an attack on African
Americans has created an environment in
which the Republican Party really has a
difficult time in the black community
and and I think it's important for the
Republicans to come to grips with that
history and then try to build on it and
move in a direction that works not just
for African Americans but for the whole
country and so brick-by-brick
this wall has been constructed I believe
that brick by brick that wall can be
deconstructed but it's up to the party
and activists to get together they make
that happen thank you very much
before before we take your questions on
I'm gonna acknowledge breath pillai he
was my graduate assistant helping me he
volunteered to help me do some of the
research and he's satting on on an
interview with me and i just wanted to
thank you for coming and and also
acknowledged that you're Philadelphia
Eagles got brutalized this message is
directed read media a whole bunch of
other Republicans I'm the Republican
National Committee for the district and
I so acknowledge this issue it's a very
very major issue sixty percent of the
city is african-american and we can't
have a voice in the city in this movie
chuckle yeah
if so say okay how do you do it we first
the first argument was african-americans
you you won't get elope you won't get
place at the table if one party takes
you for granted and the other party in
your shoe then what happens is everybody
ignores you into a great before an
election Republicans say there's no
chance so we don't make any effort and
the African and the Democrats demonize
the Republicans in an effort to get out
without african-american votes that
doesn't work the part that's are crazy
in my own mind is that so many of the
things that Republicans stand for like
Family Values like on education child
trophy next to being a properly educated
are suitable to what the Republicans say
and also president in the African
American community but it's really tough
I think the real tipping point was
though in 1968 when Richard Nixon saw
the opportunity by how angry the
Southern Democrats were with civil
rights acts that he saw an opportunity
to win the presidency by going after the
Southern Democrats they had historically
been racist and got them into the
Republican Party and that was sort of
the final straw that seemed overly too
so it's an interesting problem and I'm
delighted well thank you I would just
say two things one there were a number
of straws and you know that I go through
the book and lay out all of these sort
of political symbol symbols that have
been used to sort of turn away and
demonize African Americans so well I
think your point is well-taken I would
suggest to you that you know you could
go back to the Goldwater campaign of 64
or fast-forward the clock to the
President President Reagan opposing a
Martin Luther King holiday you know you
know you can go either way with that now
in terms of some of the issues that you
raised you mentioned family values and
and I'm glad you did that because
African Americans I believe view that
issue a little wider than the Republican
Party does the Republican Party in in
large measure based on the national
conventions the National candidates and
sort of the national political
leadership has defined family values
rather narrowly okay let's keep getting
from getting married
let's keep women from having choice and
let's do all that we can to make sure
that that's the only way we view family
values now the reason why the Democrats
have been more successful with African
Americans with this issue of Family
Values is what about health care and
housing and income generation and
justice you know those can also be seen
as family about family values in
addition to the whole range of other
other points that can be made in their
regard so from my perspective every time
the Republicans say Family Values in
many years of African Americans they're
hearing something different so I would
say that there is a disconnect in the
language that is being used when
Republicans say law-and-order
african-americans here let's lock up
more black people
you know President Bush came into power
and president him in with the Latino
vote he knew about them in text and I'm
from Texas
big citrus in Texas tea no vote and
there have been some you proud of her
it's saying that they thought that that
monarchy was going to take all in the
processing of the vote that the blacks
were giving to the Republican Party by
them recruiting and getting them the
keynote publican party how do you see
that has come since then but that's one
of the big thing that he announced the
right that worked on the expectation was
that President Bush would not only bring
in more Latinos but also more African
Americans because he had so much success
with black voters in Texas when even his
two campaigns a governor a couple things
got in the way one of this immigration
issue has sort of forced his hand in
terms of where the party is going I
believe that he's far more moderate on
immigration than the rest of the part so
that's the problem I think as it relates
to going forward the partners gonna have
a very difficult time rebuilding that
bridge and in fact when you look at
where the party stands with
african-americans and where the parties
the party is with african-americans
where it will ultimately be with Latino
voters I believe because the immigration
issue isn't going away and there are
those in the Republican Party who want
to use immigration with Latino voters as
they did sort of law and order with
african-american voters and so again I
think there's a new generation of
symbolism there's this joke going on
that Brown is the new black as it
relates to as it relates to Republican
Party symbolism our for granted
and eighty ninety seven ninety eighty
seven before Bush got older but as a
political consultant on the Republican
side now you'd be amazed at some of the
comments I have to deal with when we're
sitting in the private meeting so one of
my observations did I was telling
Senator Jim DeMint from South Carolina a
couple weeks ago the Republican Party
based on that nexus I wasn't strategies
from sixty when maxed out the white male
book ain't having no more babies how do
you go and this is what I'm saying to
the party since you've maxed out the
white male voter unless you do something
with the black and Hispanic community
they know else for you to grow and so I
think until the party starts dealing
with that ceiling with the white male
voter who is the most conservative
demographic group we're going to
continue to be in the minority and one
thing I was working on the op-ed piece
basically advocating blacks should stop
trying to diversify the Republican Party
and the Republican Party should stop
even making overture at the black
community because they're not serious
about it and when you look at the RNC
today even on the kid Melman Melman had
zero blacks on his personal staff as it
is today the Senatorial Committee the
House Campaign Committee most Hill
staffers are not quiet so until you deal
with those issues you can have the best
friends in the world until you get along
the ground floor and these auxiliaries
within the party yeah we just kind of
whistling Dixie no pun intended
you know I can only imagine that for
those Republican african-american
Republican activists who have to go out
and defend this stuff and that's the
other thing you know there is a carry of
African American Republicans who believe
deeply in and the party's values but
continually have to hit their heads
against the wall in defending the party
in one way or another and so until you
begin to get some movement in that area
and I totally agree that is one area
that sort of underplayed but matters to
people who pay attention I think you're
going to continue that problem
expression they do you think that the
Republican Party might have a rose or
has had inroads
it's by a religious identity I think
that was an area that could have been
plumbed but the faith may the
faith-based initiative has actually
turned out to be a disappointment among
some African Americans when you look at
all of the money that's being spent very
little of it actually trickles into
black communities and so many
african-americans have supported the
faith-based initiative did so on the
expectation that there will be
additional resources committed that they
can have some some direction over which
they can have some direction and that
hasn't happened and and again there are
a number of African American religious
leaders who also Republicans who are
angry with the party on that particular
issue so if you can't do it through
faith and that appears to be the the
best way to do it then I think you have
real problems
George Mason University and all our good
friends here thank you all so much for
coming in thank you Michael Floyd for
coming and presenting some of the ideas
in your
[Music]
michael font Roy's book party was hosted
by George Mason University and the
American Political Science Association
for more on his work visit Michael
Fauntroy calm